España Avanza en el cumplimiento de la
ley de memoria democrática que desde
octubre de 2022 condena por primera vez
explícitamente el golpe de estado que
desencadenó en la Guerra Civil Española
entre 1936 y 39 y la posterior dictadura
los restos mortales de una de las
figuras principales del fascismo español
José Antonio primo de Ribera fundador de
la falange española y fusilado por el
bando republicano en el 36 han sido
trasladados a un cementerio de Madrid
desde la basílica del Valle de los
caídos un mausoleo católico construido
por presos políticos durante la
dictadura de Francisco Franco y que el
gobierno quiere ahora reconvertir en un
lugar de homenaje y reconocimiento de
todas las víctimas de la Guerra Civil
Española la exhumación de primo de
ribera se celebró por voluntad de la
familia y a puertas cerradas Aunque a la
llegada al cementerio en el centro de
Madrid se dieron altercados entre
policía y unos 200 falangistas que
quisieron entrar al recinto tres de
ellos fueron detenidos Este es otro paso
más tras la exhumación en 2019 del
dictador Franco enterrado en el Valle de
los caídos tras su muerte en 1975 en el
monumento de la hora conocido como Valle
de cuelgamuros a unos 50 kilómetros de
la capital española hay enterradas más
de 33.800 personas pertenecientes a
ambos bandos que murieron durante el
conflicto el siguiente paso del gobierno
será exhumar los restos de 118 personas
asesinadas por los franquistas que han
sido reclamados por sus familiares